les mencioné en los vídeos pasados que
las dos cosas más importantes que deben
conocer en termodinámica es que bueno
que la presión inicial por el volumen
inicial
y esto es una constante también si
dividimos entre la temperatura verdad
esto va a ser igual a una constante y es
por lo tanto la presión final por el
volumen final y si lo dividimos entre la
temperatura final debe ser exactamente
igual que cuando que con los datos
iniciales verdad la otra cosa que
deberían recordar es que la presión por
el volumen es igual a n porque es el
número de moles por cierto mol eso es
como decir docenas simplemente que es
más o menos 6 por 10 a la 23 por r que
es la constante universal de gas que es
8.31 jules / / será 8.31 8.21 8.31 jules
ok déjenme anotarlo 8.31 jules / mol por
kelvin por la temperatura y recuerden
para de estar muy seguros siempre hay
que convertir a kelvin ahora veamos si
podemos hacer
un problema que involucre esta situación
digamos que tenemos un globo ok y el
volumen de ese globo es este un metro
cúbico digamos ok entonces tenemos un
metro cúbico de este muy grande globo
verdad digo es muy grande imagínense un
metro cúbico de un globo entonces pero
bueno la presión digamos que son 55
pascal es 5 pascal es que son newtons /
metro cuadrado no recuerdo exactamente
que les dije en los vídeos anteriores
pero un pascal es un newton entre metro
cuadrado y digamos que tenemos una
temperatura razonablemente bien digamos
son 20 grados centígrados ok y digamos
que el globo está lleno de helio ok
entonces mi pregunta para ustedes es
cuántas moléculas de helio tengo en el
globo entonces vamos a sustituir en la
ecuación y ya lo tendremos resuelto
verdad entonces la presión es 5
ok recuerden siempre poner las unidades
que es newtons por metro cuadrado o que
es lo mismo de jules / metro al cubo /
metros cúbicos verdad por el volumen que
es un metro cúbico es igual a n por r
que es 8.31 jules / mol por kelvin ok
por la temperatura y otra vez recuerden
no lo puedo poner en grados celsius
tengo que ponerlo en grados kelvin así
que si esto es nuestro nuestra
temperatura en series hay que agregarle
273 que al final nos quedan 293 grados
que aquí tenemos entonces 5 podemos
cancelar un metro cuadrado y nos quedan
en jules verdad que es newton / metro
por n por 8.31 jules / mol porque el
bean que se cancelan con los de la
temperatura y entonces simplemente hay
que calcular esto esta multiplicación de
y 8.31 por 293
y eso es 2400 34.83 jules por mol
2400 34.83 jules formol
jules news por mod
entonces para obtener el número de moles
simplemente dividimos ambos lados por
este término verdad y las unidades
funcionan bastante bien así que n va a
ser igual
55 jules 5 jules por 1 entre 2400 34.83
y aquí multiplicamos por el inverso de
las unidades que es metros perdón moles
entre ellos así que estos se cancelan y
todo esto me queda exactamente en moles
verdad entonces dividimos 5 entre 2400
34.83 y nos da 0.002 moles
aproximadamente
así que esto es igual a punto 0 021
moles
y eso y eso puede parecer un número muy
pequeño para ustedes pero bueno vamos a
descubrir cuántas moléculas son ok
entonces de hecho déjenme hacer un
espacio y para que podamos escribir el
número de avogadro
vamos a borrar todo esto muy bien ahora
sí ya tengo espacio
entonces el número de abogados de hecho
creo que no les he mencionado lo que es
el número de avogadro verdad bueno es el
número de moléculas por mol
simplemente entonces el número de
avogadro es igual a 6.0 22 por 10 a la
23 moléculas por mol
o que es simplemente el número que ya
teníamos entonces sí teníamos 0.00 21
moles cuántas moléculas tengo
simplemente multiplicamos 0.00 21 x
cuántas moléculas por mol tengo que es
el número de avogadro
es decir esto por el número de avogadro
es eso que está allá arriba y eso es en
moles por molécula por perdón moléculas
por mol ok entonces estas cosas se
cancelan y simplemente me queda el
número de avogadro que 6 puntos 0 22 por
10 a la veintitrés eso no lo puedo
escribir aquí pero acuérdense de él
simplemente lo vamos a multiplicar al
final y esto x 0.00 21 y eso es igual a
0.01 26
punto 0 1 26 por 10 a la 23
moléculas por supuesto estamos hablando
ya de moléculas entonces esto es punto 0
126 esto es lo mismo que digamos en
términos de notación científica es 1.26
por 10 o más bien por punto 01 verdad
por 10 a la 23 0.01 eso qué es eso
simplemente es 10 a la menos 2 verdad
esto es 10 a la menos 2
y entonces tenemos un 1.26
ok por 10 a la menos 2 y que se
multiplica por 10 a las 23 10 a la 21
verdad leyes de los exponentes entonces
aproximadamente es 1.26 acompañada de
otros que serán 19 ceros
ok es la cantidad de moléculas de helio
que tengo la parte difícil es realmente
acordarse del número de avogadro y de la
constante universal de gases que es 8.31
de l'esport mol por kelvin y bueno
acordándose que hay que convertir a
grados kelvin para que todo jale a veces
puede ser un poco truculento quizás el
volumen se lo den en litros hay que
convertirlo a metros cúbicos
antes de hacerlo quizás la presión te lo
den en atmósferas o qué sé yo tienes que
saber la conversión para pasarlo a
pascal es oa newtons por metro cuadrado
en fin esto todo es sustitución y toda
la matemática peluda que puede salir
espero que esto haya sido clarificante
nos vemos